Можемо розпочинати
Добре Отже Вітаю всіх учасників цього
вебінару дуже раді що ви сьогодні
підключилися п'ятниця сподіваємося що у
вас будуть Гарні вихідні але останній
гривок дуже цікавий сподіваємося буду
для вас сьогоднішній вебінар і нагадаю
нагадаю що вебінар в нас називається
базові правила Для успішного віддаленого
навчання і ми дуже раді що дуже багато
учасників виявили інтерес Ми отримали
більш ніж тисячу реєстрацій менш ніж за
один тиждень
сьогоднішня спікерка - це е-е пані
Маргарита Носкова вона є експерткою з
дистанційного навчання і вона розвиває
цю галузь в Україні вже більше 20 років
Вона розкаже більше про себе коли
розпочне презентацію а перш ніж ми
почали Я хотіла б нагадати про те що
Міністерство освіти і науки України
наприкінці Минулого року запустило
професійну освіту онлайн це платформа на
якій учні та викладачі профтехів можуть
навчатися та навчати онлайн
на цій платформі вже розміщено близько
30 курсів і кожен день якісь цих курсів
росте здебільшого це курси з різних
професій про технічних але також там є
окрема галузь з яка називається ключові
компетенції і більш інформації про цю
платформу ви можете знайти на сайті
Міністерства власне сім'ї платформі Я
додаю зараз посилання на цю платформу у
наш чат у Зумі І власне заохочуємо всіх
користуватися цією платформою заходити і
досліджувати дистанційно навчання онлайн
і саме тому Сьогодні ми зібралися разом
із Маргаритою щоб вона нам допомогла е-е
з тим як створювати гарний якісний
освітній контент онлайн
і
технічний момент я хотіла б сказати що
ця презентація зараз відбувається у Зумі
Ти також транслюється у Ютубі в нас
багато
переглядів і
залишиться на Ютубі і також перед
початком надам слово Олексію ситнику
Олексій Якщо можете представити себе
будь ласка і е-е Так дякую доброго
Доброго дня шановні колеги Зараз я
спробую ще й себе включити
для того щоб на Ютубі Ми не бачили та й
так я Всіх вітаю вітаю вас Від
міністерства від імені команди підтримки
реформ
можливо багато з вас Ми не бачили Я
їздив в регіони до вас саме з Іриною
володимирівною Шумик з генеральної
директоркою директорату
їздили досліджувати як працюють це людям
регіонах в цих складних теперішніх
умовах власне про складні умови в першу
чергу Мабуть мені варто подякувати за
той подвиг я не побоюсь цього пафосного
слова які ви зараз робите Бо насправді
без ну Іноді на зустрічі з нами з вашими
колегами з директорами закладів просто
неможливо було сидіти без слів і без
сліз і
власне про платформу як каже є в нас
платформа вона називається профосвіта
онлайн домен так і звучить профосвіта
онлайн от Я сподіваюсь ви про неї знаєте
для чого наш сьогоднішній вебінар знову
ж таки коли я їжджу до вас в гості я вам
прямо в очі всім кажу що професія Як ви
знаєте да за якими ми здійснюємо
підготовку там більше 400 і навчальних
матеріалів одночасно на всі набрати ну
практично неможливо це колосальний обсяг
інформації
відповідно Я всілякова вас прошу
заохочую брати участь дистанційному
навчанні брати участь в створенні
контенту для дистанційної освіти і
відповідно всю свою діяльність спрямовую
на те щоби допомогти вам в цьому Так ми
пишемо проекти з тим щоби з'явились
з'явились нове обладнання в закладах
професійної освіти Ми проводимо навчання
щодо створення освіт контенту недавно
закінчився курс з артикулей сторін 3 Та
де найкраще
учні здобувачі цього курсу отримали
ліцензії на Це дороговартісна програмне
забезпечення і ось сьогодні завдяки
міжнародній організації праці за
допомогою лінзи з допомогою пані
Маргарити носкової ми проводимо ще один
вебінар який стосується того як власне
організовувати дистанційне навчання
Дякую всім хто зібрався Дякую за ваших
майже тисячу заявок на участь На жаль
ми не змогли всіх в зон пустити саме
тому організовуємо трансляцію ще раз
дуже дякую вам за вашу активність і
гарного вам вебінару
Дякую Олексій і на цьому хочу заохотити
всіх активно Приймати участь в цьому
вебінарі це в нас не буде лекція в
класичному розумінні цього слова це буде
дійсно інтерактивне
роботи разом з Маргаритою і маргарито
запрошую вас Будь ласка
Можемо розпочинати дякую дякую Ліза Я
дуже сподіваюсь що ви мені допоможете
тому що без вашої допомоги мені не
вдасться провести весь інтерактив
залучаю і прошу долучатися активно до
роботи і наших
глядачів які зараз перебувають в YouTube
каналі і з вашого дозволу відразу
розпочинаю трансляцію
презентації будемо з вами працювати над
складним і не дуже складним питанням
базові правила успішного віддаленого або
дистанційного навчання власне
віддаленого ключове слово давайте
використовувати українські слова Але тим
не менш спочатку про мене чому я
можу
претендувати на те щоб говорити на цю
тему я працюю в національному
університеті Львівська політехніка на
кафедрі педагогіки інноваційної освіти є
директором центру інноваційних освітніх
технологій мають доволі солідний стаж і
понад 15 років займаюсь дистанційним
навчанням ще в ті часи коли здавалося що
дистанційне навчання це щось
дуже-дуже-дуже інноваційне дуже далекий
зовсім не про наші заклади освіти автор
багатьох дистанційних курсів ви понад
6,5 тисяч слухачів до цих курсів успішно
його їх завершили Сьогодні я постараюсь
поговорити про
дистанційне або віддалене навчання
без прив'язок до інструментів до
платформ до ресурсів ми поговоримо з
вами власне про дистанційне Як таке що
це просто через якісь елементарні речі і
асоціації
в першу чергу хочу відразу вас запросити
до
опитування так що ви використовуєте під
час дистанційного навчання ви бачите
перед собою посилання бачити код і
бачите qr-код якщо
віза мені допоможе зараз в чаті у вас
з'явиться Аналогічно тяж-інформація
скористайтеся будь ласка нею і
постарайтеся надати відповіді на ті
запитання
Я почекаю кілька секунд і на цей час за
цей час зазначу що як правило ми з вами
під час
карантину вперше стикнулися з таким
масовим дистанційним навчанням і це було
як в казці за одну ніч
ще вчора ми з вами вчилися звичного
аудиторії а через
добу Ми всі з вами опинились в онлайні
як Аліса в країні див
єдина відмінність була в тому що ніхто
нас не вчив Що треба робити І оце
Задзеркаллі в якому опинилися всі
педагоги в багатьох країнах світу
отримували певну підтримку і
заохочення в першу чергу в закладах
загальної середньої освіти вищої освіти
а профтехосвіта залишилося на принципі
дайте собі якось Раду самі І от ми з
вами потихесенько цю Раду собі давали
давайте з вами зараз я Зупиню
демонстрацію і перейду в інший на іншу
сторіночку для того щоб показати вам Які
результати У нас є а результат дуже
гарний він мене дуже тішить як правило
зовсім іншу картинку я бачу але тим не
менш хочу вам похвалитися Подивіться
Який чудовий результат
зазначили ось ми бачимо 27 відсотків
наголошують що всі інструменти
використовують і я пропонувала вебінари
відеомедіа медіа матеріали є взаємодії
спілкування колекція навчальних ресурсів
середовища і інструкція і ви бачите що
кількість зростає Давайте ми ще трошечки
почекаємо в чаті Я зараз верну
інформацію на екран
нашу презентацію так
і продовжу
видно мою презентацію Ліза прекрасно
Отже я зупинюсь опитування ще працює Ми
можемо з ним ще працювати я прошу
скористатися можливістю надати відповіді
для нас це важливо але я потихесенько
буду рухатися далі І відразу пропозиція
лізе зараз мені допоможе і нам треба
написати в чат які асоціації викликає в
вас Ось така картинка
Як ви думаєте що це таке
У нас вже з'являються відповіді борщ
прозвучала декілька разів так прямо
відразу борщ так чудово серце
але здебільшого борщ є ще овочі буряк
так бурячки бурячки прекрасно Все
правильно це бурячки але це все складно
Клопотенко
звичайно в нас
буряк викликає для всіх українців
викликає одну єдину реакцію це борщ але
Уявіть собі що у нас немає буряка
чи може бути борщ без буряка
не може борщ без буряка буде не може
жодним чином борщ - це ціла історія це
натхнення це ідея - це процес це
інгредієнти це інструменти це безліч
згадок емоції і вражать от все це разом
і утворює
наше українське явище воші
віддалене навчання це те саме в борщі
Немає нічого зайвого щоби не додавали в
кожному регіоні країни хтось робить з
фасолю хтось з грибами хтось
з пелюшками але в любому випадку це борщ
тому що там є
буряки і оцей особливий інгредієнт Який
в нас має
часник і ще якісь там спеції це все
правильно
віддалене навчання так само цілком і
повністю залежить від того процесу і тих
інгредієнтів які ми туди додаємо
тривалий час ми не знали що ж саме це
таке і робили за принципом що у нас під
руками що є вмію що я знаю де я її
використовую Таким чином я її будую свої
заняття я намагаюся підлаштуватися під
обставин Але по суті
дистанційне або віддалене навчання це
звична освітня технологія для нас вже
звично а раз вона освітня технологія
вона будується на законах дидактики а
дидактика технічна ми з вами в
дидактичних документах методиці
технологіях прекрасно зрозуміємо що ми
знаємо як це робити Ми також знаємо що
дистанційна освіта - це форма навчання А
раз так значить воно повинно перебувати
в якомусь місці І використовувати якісь
інструменти
особливістю дистанційного віддаленого
навчання це те що всі ці інструменти це
середовище електронне і ми скористаємо в
першу чергу тим що
пропонує нам
локальна мережа хмарні сервіси і
інтернет давайте з вами тепер про це
поговоримо більш детально
якщо у вас з'являються якісь коментарі
зауваження ідеї думки Я дуже вас прошу
писати про це в чаті тому що Ліза буде
мені допомагати і це буде допомагати
мені Вести з вами невеличкий діалог Отже
якщо ми живемо з вами за правилами і за
законами дидактики в закладі освіти так
і
дотримуємося правила від простого до
складного від зрозумілого знайомого до
незнайомого послідовності поступовости і
необхідності
за запитами суспільства то в любому
випадку ми прекрасно можемо облаштувати
своє навчання свою роботу в середовищі
однак
дистанційному навчанні є кілька
особливостей які докорінно відрізняють
нас від навчання в звичайному аудиторії
в звичайному класі І власне дотримання
цих правил
обумовлює успішність цього процесу якщо
ми нехтуємо його ними і намагаємося
перенести звичайне навчання в монітор
так через монітор помістити туди
аудиторію ми програємо давайте з вами
зупинимось більше детально Отже ви
бачите я зазначила п'ять позицій
мотивація вибір взаємодія присутність і
завершеність ось я зараз постараюся
швидесенько пройтись по кожній позиції
ще раз наголошую не буду зупинятися на
жодних інструментах на жодних платформах
а говоримо в принципі про те що нами
повинно керувати коли ми з вами
пропонуємо або працюємо онлайн з учнями
або все ж таки дистанційно До речі
хотіла походи відразу питання Напишіть
будь ласка в чаті Як ви думаєте онлайн
навчання і дистанційне навчання це
синоніми чи є між ними якась різниця
Ліза буде дивитися за цим А я поки
розказую про мотивацію
мотивація дуже важливо взагалі в
будь-якому навчанні в будь-якому процесі
Що ми робимо але
віддаленому навчанні надзвичайно важливо
щоб
мотивація була спільна у того хто навчає
і у того хто вчить
Ось тут в віддаленому навчанні в ідеалі
працює
індивідуальний підхід і принцип
дитиноцентризму коли в центрі уваги
потреби учня потреби студента але все ж
таки вони повинні повністю співвідносити
з тим як це робить вчитель Ми повинні
навчитися разом вчитися і вчити вчитися
трохи масло масляне пояснює якщо ми
маємо чітку мету і наша мета співпадає
наша мається на увазі мене як вчителя і
моїх студентів моїх учнів процес
відбувається набагато швидше тому що ми
один одного розуміємо коли ми з вами
знаходимось в аудиторії нам легше цю
мету сконцентрувати і за собою повести
наших вихованців так тих що навчаються
на відстані це зробити складніше Тому
треба дуже чітко формулювати
навчальну мету і те чого ви від них
хочете отримати
в кінці який результат ви прагнете
отримати він повинен бути конкретний не
можна сказати що нам сьогодні треба
вивчити всі можливі
способи Я не знаю там
створення якихось заготовок
Ми повинні зазначити що сьогодні ми
будемо створювати таку-то і таку-то
заготовку до такої-то і такої-то роботи
чіткість і зрозумілість зазначена в меті
значно підвищує мотивацію тому що учень
або студент розуміє може він це зробити
не може він розуміє шлях чи не розуміє
Ну приблизно можу навести вам простий
дуже приклад
можемо зазначити що колеги ми їдемо в
Швейцарії
це дуже загальна мета але якщо я вам
сконцентрую вашу увагу і зазначу що на
наступному тижні всі хто має паспорт
закордонний і бажання взяти участь у
такому-то проекті маємо можливість
продовж години зареєструватися і поїде у
Швейцарії зауважте мета та сама але
формулювання більш конкретне і ми
розуміємо ті обмеження які нам в нас
виникають надзвичайно важливим в
мотивації і те що я можу тому що коли ми
працюємо в аудиторії нам значно простіше
звернутися до викладача і зазначити що я
не можу цього зробити я не розумію як це
робити в дистанційному навчанні цей
процес трошки ускладнюється тому що ми
можемо не співпадати в часі або під час
онлайн В мене нема можливості задати
питання викладачу моя мотивація до
навчання падає І ще одне навички
ще раз наголошую важливу те що вміє і
вчитель і викладач і учень студент
повинні бути приблизно однаковими в
плані цифрової цифрової грамотності Ми
повинні вміти це робити однаково добре в
ідеалі вчитель краще ніж учень ну це не
завжди виходить Але тим не менш цей
процес постійно розвивається і Треба
віддати належне щоб дистанційному
навчанні ми ділимо відповідальність за
одержання результату Якщо студент чогось
не зміг це значить викладач щось погано
пояснив або розмістив неповну інформацію
не
докладно інструкція не
деталізував якісь моменти і в результаті
щось залишилося за кадром будь ласка
Еліза Які в нас результати дистанційний
онлайн - це однакове це синоніми чи ні в
нас консенсус в чаті всі кажуть про те
що не ні це не одне й те саме І також
деякий учасники додали вважають що
дистанційне навчання це є більш ширше
поняття і що онлайн це
підвид дистанційного навчання і що
онлайн навчання передбачає синхрон
дистанційне не обов'язково Прекрасно у
нас чудова аудиторія ви прекрасно
правильно зазначаєте що дистанційне
навчання має значно ширше поняття це
асинхрон І синхрон це те що з чим ми
працюємо постійно в різний час в різному
місці а онлайн це обов'язково певний час
за певним
локальним посиланням та викликання і в
певному середовищі власне і це ми
переходимо і до наступного кроку вибір
в житті взагалі вибір - це найскладніша
річ
від нього дуже багато завершить інколи
доля і майбутнє
в дистанційному віддаленому навчанні
ключовим є вибір середовища де
відбувається навчальний процес
тому що закони законами мета інструменти
методи результати все це дуже добре якщо
воно зосереджено в середовищі в якому
легко працювати яке
інтуїтивно зрозуміле яке забезпечує
захищеність можливість єдиного входу
особливо зараз актуальне це питання для
наших учнів
збільшує частини країни тому що
атаки небезпека
витік персональних даних врешті-решт
просто доступ до інтернету
зважаючи на те що в нас є частини дітей
які навчаються з окупованих територій де
окупованих територій з проблеми з
інтернетом все це дуже впливає на якість
навчання але середовище яке дозволяє
працювати І синхронізуватися з off і
онлайн Так середовище яке дозволяє входу
через єдину кнопку яке дозволяє
інтегрувати зовнішні ресурси
дуже-дуже-дуже допомагає процесу
навчання але треба зважити ще на одне
невеличкий заклад освіти не потребує
дуже такого потужного якогось середовища
Для цього можна використовувати
середовище яке пропонує наприклад
Міністерство освіти і науки України або
яке розгортається в межах територіальної
громади або в межах області або
використовується відкриті ресурси все це
Добре але нам завжди треба зважати на
кілька моментів наші сервери повинні
знаходитись в Україні тому що всі дані
які ми з вами розміщуємо в цьому
середовищі це наше напрацювання це те
ще повинно залишатися в нашому в нашій
країні Наші учні повинні мати гарантію
того що їх персональні дані їх
напрацювання їх досвід і викладачі також
не стануть надбанням ворога і ще
надзвичайно важливо результат який
напрацьовується в цьому середовищі
повинен зберігатися в тривалий час а
якщо він зберігається тривалий час то
робота викладача суттєво спрощується ми
з вами можемо вдосконалювати те що
створили в минулому або позаминулому
році використовувати ресурси які колись
були методичними як дидактичний
результат як те
роботи учнів за їх згоди наголошує ми
можемо зробити дидактичний матеріалом
для подальших наступних курсів наступних
студентів які будуть навчатися за цією
спеціальністю ми можемо використовувати
ширше інструменти
і методики навчання все це працює тільки
за умови що все це правильно і системно
організовано в одному середовищі
вибір середовища має певні критерії Я
зараз на цьому не зупиняюсь в наше з
вами сьогодні оглядову лекція але
надзвичайно важливим - це також є
наступним важливим етапом є взаємодія і
присутність дуже часто вважають що
дистанційне навчання не забезпечує
ефективної взаємодії і навіть
соціалізації і ми не можемо якісно
спілкуватися онлайн і в дистанційці
взагалі не можемо і забезпечити
присутність викладача в цьому середовищі
Ну воно дуже опосередковане Я думаю що
це не зовсім правдива річ Я вам зараз
покажу просто невеличку схемку про неї
можна більш детально говорити на окремих
курсах більш деталізовано найбільше
вебінарах але зараз зупинюся на
ключовому наш навчальний процес він так
і названий процес складається з певного
набору з своїх дій Так це власне
навчання спілкування навчальної не
тільки поза навчальна може бути контроль
і моніторинг ефективності цього процесу
от все це разом це такі знаєте три
клітини яких тримається будь-яке освіта
будь-яке навчальний процес
паралельно в нас можуть відбуватися
якісь додаткові заходи тут дуже класно
ще якісь маленькі дрібненькі речі є але
в будь-якому процесі все це виливається
у наступний етап контроль і зворотний
зв'язок якщо ось це спілкування на етапі
процесу навчального є ефективним і
вчитель або викладач своїми учнями або
студентами
вміє І правильно використовувати
інструментарій для забезпечення
взаємодії із зворотнього зв'язку то не
етапі аналізу в дистанційному навчанні
контроль перестає бути тим думокливим
мечем які загрожує і лякає будь-кого хто
навчається Так це стає етапом який
дозволяє побачити зміни власного
власного розвитку свою власну динаміку
власне за що люблю віддалене навчання це
дуже індивідуалізований процес в
масовому потоці коли є дуже багато людей
але все ж таки ми з вами Працюємо з
кожним учням окремо і
перевіряючи роботи ми пишемо коментарі
долучаємо якісь зауваження Ми даємо
можливість
переробити і виправити якісь речі ми
дуже активно взаємодіємо через
форумичати за допомогою різноманітних
відкритих запитань є дуже багато
інструментарій які дозволяє це зробити
опускаю вже тему вебінарів і онлайнових
занять Звичайно Це просто
прекрасний інструмент який дозволяє
відслідковувати і працювати з кожним але
ось весь цей результат і дає пам'ятаєте
на першому моєму слайді про мотивацію
був кінцевий результат За який Ми
однаково відповідаємо із учнями і
викладачі для того щоб цей результат був
якісним
дуже страшним а навчальний процес
ефективним обов'язковим є
явна і прихована присутність викладача
для цього є цілий
ряд інструментів в аудиторія ми з вами
для цього використовуємо тон
тембр манеру висловлювати свою думку Так
використовуємо дуже багато різноманітних
якихось рухів жестів міміки все це можна
робити і за допомогою слова якщо ми з
вами правильно розміщаємо інформацію от
в тому єдиному середовищі в якому
навчаються Наші учні де Ми розміщуємо
свої курси
це може бути і за допомогою відео і
медіа і може бути через підказки це може
бути прекрасно просто звичайною мовою
якою ми пишемо текст інструкції або
настанови для виконання практичного
завдання або пояснюємо практичну річ
коли ми коментуємо наступний слайд який
дозволяє при виборі тої чи іншої
відповіді отримати Відмінно так
відмінне зауваження інше не такий як у
[музика]
за іншою відповіді Да трошки масло-масло
не вийшло в будь-якому випадку
дистанційне або віддалене навчання з
одної сторони ускладнює роботу тому що є
багато інструментарій тому що дуже
багато часу на початку Ми витрачаємо на
те щоб створити навчальний контент
вибрати його використати знову ж таки
Хочу наголосити що для цього треба
використовувати вже готові ресурси від
досвідчених
авторів які вже щось створили Навіщо ви
знаходите велосипед якщо його вже
створили краще удосконалити його під
себе під своїх учнів власне для цього і
Міністерство освіти і науки зробило дуже
багато зараз ресурсних матеріалів які
дозволяють цим скористатися але
наскільки добре Ви вмієте організувати
зворотний зв'язок розмістити інформацію
на екрані так щоб кожен квадратний
сантиметр цього екрану працював на
поставленому то залежить виключно
викладача власне про це ми теж можемо з
вами поговорити якщо у вас ця тема
зацікавить Але у будь-якому варіанті ми
з вами повинні прийти до кінцевого
результату і ось тут ще одна помилка яку
ми часто робимо коли проводимо заняття
онлайн
або коли працюємо дистанційно і
розміщаємо матеріали навчальні на
дистанційних платформах - це
плавне перетікання завдання в завдання
не без фіксації завершеності
коли ми проводимо заняття в аудиторії У
нас все знаєте як річка тече поступово
одне за другим переходить і дитина або
студент більш дорослий так він
включається в цей процес
це специфіка аудиторного заняття а от
робота в аудиторії віртуальній потребує
постійного такого контролю чикліста так
фіксованості виконання завдань нас чітко
зазначена мета Яка
прописує етапи його виконання ця
прописана мета передбачає можливість
студента або учня
умовно самостійно позначити це я виконав
це я зрозумів отут мені треба задати
запитання
це мені не відкрилось в мене повинна
бути можливість давати зворотній зв'язок
викладачу для цього повинна бути Довіра
Але з іншої сторони і Викладач повинен
мати можливість відслідкувати сам себе
про
рефлексувати чи добре я розмістив
матеріал чи не забагато інформації
розміщено чи читається вона чи
сприймається вона для цього є цілий ряд
інструментів професійних платформах є
цілий ряд інструментів які дозволяє
відслідкувати ефективність кожного з
завдань як можна з цим робити ну знову ж
таки це окрема тема для розмови але
зараз Хочу наголосити що в будь-якому
завданні Ми повинні зафіксувати
завершення і задати запитання
розтягнуто мети собі як викладачу
студенту як в тому що навчається і разом
колезі чим добре В мене все це вийшло в
дистанційному найкраще працюється коли
кожен сам Але разом з іншими і цей
зворотній зв'язок повинен стати часткою
навчального процесу часткою яка дає
можливість рухатися вперед вертаючись до
нашої першої теми першого мови
мотивованості коли всі спільно прагнуть
одної мети навчитися і навчити того
заради чого ми всі з вами прийшли у
навчальний заклад
і зараз
підсумок
мушу витримати як кажуть театрально так
раз я говорю про завершення прошу вас
Перейти за qr-кодом за посиланням так
дати відповідь на запитання що була
корисна інформація яку я зараз вам
розповіла і буквально
10 секунд на те щоби у нас була
можливість це виконати зробити
поки Можливо хтось вже дасть дав
відповідь на запитання і зараз у вас є
питання до мене я з радістю на них
відповім Ліза слідкує за нашим чатом ви
можете писати Також я постараюсь
відслідкувати от мене тут паралельно
відкрито онлайн трансляція для того щоб
якщо є запитання і там їх прочитати
Можливо у вас є якісь зауваження про
позиції заперечення або
потреба ви би хотіли про щось дізнатися
більше будь ласка
поки що я думаю учасники переходять по
посиланню або через qr-код нагадаю що ви
можете ставити запитання
в чаті або піднімати руку і ми будемо
запрошувати вас до слова
голоса так би мовити Так звичайно
чи виходить учасників перейти в і
в нас там є з'являються відповіді зараз
подивлюся я
припиню трансляцію
і зараз ми побачимо
одну хвильку самі цікаво
Зараз ми побачимо які у нас результат
і виведу з радістю на екран Мені дуже
приємно це бачити похвалюсь
Ось такі у нас результат
все ж таки користь була
Хоча є один відсоток який так і не
визначився чи було це цікаво Але
Я думаю що це ще цікавіше буде якщо ми з
вами тепер поспілкуємося і я з радістю
відповім на будь-які ваші запитання які
виникли можливо асоціації емоції
враження
є ще пару коментарів у чаті в Ютубі
кажуть що інформація була корисною і
цікавою Дякую дуже доволі складно такий
великий об'ємний матеріал помістити в
півгодини та ще й без використання
конкретних інструментів і платформ не
уявляєте наскільки складно стриматись не
називаючи їх
а можливо Якщо можна я вам поставлю
запитання колеги які дистанційні
платформи ви використовуєте у своїх
закладах освіти
що у вас таке що от найбільше ефективним
власне платформи не інструмент а
платформи
в нас є одна піднята рукав від Діани
Гуцалюк Доброго дня Хмельницький
професійний ліцей електроніки ми
розгорнули платформу Work Space на
Google і дуже зручно оскільки в мене
викладачі такого старшого трошечки віку
і їм вже от я їх навчила цією платформою
користуватися там потрошечки ми
поступово цей шлях проходили і вже зараз
вони всі володіють і Google вміти
застосовують онлайн уроки ведуть і вже
по трошечки там вчаться використовувати
ще інші додатки того да Work Space у нас
вот розгортається і діти реєструються
діти з задоволенням по захищена
платформа немає ніяких додаткових там
реклам і так далі всім подобається
безлімітний Google Диск саме головне ні
в кого нічого не підвисає все
підгружається тому от в нас така а можна
я до вас питання відразу Скажіть будь
ласка як ви виходите з
з проблемою запису відео
на відео з не відео майже ніхто раніше я
записувала Бо раніше ми дозволяв
записувати відеоуроків і я ще тоді собі
на таку копілочку для себе зробила на
сьогоднішній день такої можливості нема
але ми користуємося запис екрану
програми там додаткові скачують хто там
вже якусь тобі
формується програм вже тоді йде запис
відео а далі вже там
нюанс зрозуміло
та дійсно це проблема але з іншої
сторони Ми формуємо ще додаткові цифрові
навички у наших
вчителів які викладачів які працюють з
цим Та я бачу що Ліза Ще щось є
що в нас є відповіді якими платформами
що користуються учасники і серед них
патлет Google міт Google Classroom
Microsoft times Zoom Moodle і ще нові
знання і всеосвіта
Ну от бачите як цікаво у нас складається
інформація от в тому що перерахувала
Ліза є і інструменти і платформи до
платформ все ж таки ми можемо віднести
або Google
поруч якийсь Звичайно це офіс 365 також
це платформа де можна облаштовувати і
організовувати навчальний процес
всім знайомі нові знання але воно більше
орієнтовано все ж таки під заклади
загальної середньої освіти це середня
школа Moodle ну всесвітньо відома
платформа яку використовують у всьому
світі для навчального процесу
спеціально організоване середовище а
решта все ж таки цей інструментарій це
От і є ті картопля буряк цибулька з якої
і складається оцей наш чарівний освітній
процес
Так дякую дуже Можливо ще щось можемо
зазначити спитати
я можу тільки зазначити мені так На
перший погляд здається що мудл І Google
Class зазначений найчастіше
Ну ми мусимо подякувати Google за те як
вони підійшли до
підтримки України і надали можливість
навчатися власне в цьому середовищі але
все ж таки як
отримаєш не буду говорити щоб не
викликати ніяких реакцій але хочу
зазначити що з інструментами Google я
почала працювати ще наприкінці 2000-х і
була великим великим прихильником Google
ще за часів коли він не дуже був
поширений
згодна з вами лізе дійсно
дистанційне навчання зараз найбільш в
Україні використовується Google і Moodle
це правда
колеги якщо немає запитань то я з
радістю передам слово Олексію
якщо є ще останні можливості поставити
запитання до пані Маргарити нагадаю це
можна зробити як в чаті таке підняти
руку
але Олексій можемо
потрохи піддавати підсумки
Я не знаю наскільки це буде підсумок
Дякую всім за участь
я вам Так розкажу що це у нас пані
Маргаритою про папера Ми вирішили
це я я бачу пані Маргарита мені киває
е-е значить тому якщо вам сподобалось
якщо для вас підняті теми актуальні так
якщо
ви бажаєте от серед Да вона наша розмова
на сьогодні була така типу вот тут можна
заглибитися але я не буду отут можна теж
вам багато що розказати але я не буду
називати інструментів це це ми вам таку
інтригу створили так от і якщо ви
бажаєте десь якоїсь конкретики ще
що-небудь ви можете так само написати в
чаті зараз в Zoom який ми збережемо Ну
можете написати в чаті в коментарях під
трансляцію в Ютубі які системи вам було
почути цікаво більш детально так
розраховуйте Те що це не будуть події ми
не будемо робити події якісь там довгі
годину там чи більше Та от приблизно так
як сьогодні так щось щось маленьке
конкретне там пів години розкриваємо
10-15 хвилин лишаємо на запитання от
таких Якщо нам темп накидаєте то можливо
ми тоді сплануємо трошки краще свою
подальшу діяльність А так Дякую всім за
участь Дякую Лізі дякую маргариті дякую
всім вам
Дякуємо Перемоги вам і
Дякую перемови всім прошумо як зазначив
Олексій зазначити які ці теми вам були б
цікаві до розгляду Ще раз всім Дякуємо і
Величезне дякую маргариті за підготовку
цього корисного матеріалу і до зустрічі
Дякую і вам До зустрічі Дякую
Щасливого вам спокійного вечорами
Дякуємо До побачення